as soon as you tell me i can't do
something
i'm gonna do it
[Music]
i hope that in sharing with you what
i've learned over 50 years of writing
that it will help you find your way as a
writer
[Music]
as a 12 year old i was obsessed by the
idea of growing breasts
and getting my period but there was no
place that i could read about it
when i started to write i was determined
to be honest
so i'm going to share with you the
practical side of writing
process story voice editing
dialogue and character there's nothing
more important
than character you're living with these
people
for years you had better feel for them
do some exercises have your character
write a letter
to you the first draft is pure torture
for me i hate every second of it
i have a messy mind and my writing is
a process of cleaning up the mess then
slowly
making a story i will be able to show
that to you
i got a particularly nasty review once
they got to me
and i took my typewriter and i held it
over
this arroya and i was going to throw it
in
i thought i cannot do this anymore
and then this little voice went off in
my head wait
you're gonna let this one review
stop you from writing that's crazy
that's one opinion
[Music]
i enjoy finding and supporting
new writers and this is a chance for me
to reach more of you
[Music]
i always ask myself why would anyone
write if they didn't have to
i mean it's so hard so this is
for all of you who feel that you have to
i'm judy bloom and this is my master
[Music]
class
you